was named one of Las Vegas's favorite
places to dine for lunch by eater and it
is expanding across the valley I'm
talking about maraki Greek Grill and
here to show us some of their dishes is
founder Jerry Gregorian and executive
chef Nico welcome you to thanks for
having us so good to have you this
morning looks incredible thank you and I
know Chef Nico you're going to start
preparing something for us I'm so
excited to hear about but Jerry tell us
a little bit about Meraki so Meraki the
meaning of the word it means to do
something with soul creativity and love
and that's you know every day we try to
put that behind what we do right so me
and Nico founded Rock in 2017
um at its core we wanted to be a fast
casual restaurant but we wanted it to be
more than that right so
um yeah so every day we go into work and
obviously you know sourcing out our
product our restaurants are beautifully
designed we just want to make sure we
take everything into consideration and
um we were able to come up with
something special we're very lucky that
the neighborhood kind of embraced us now
you guys are both from Greece right well
Nico's back on this from Greece I'm
actually born in la oh you are but you
have the Greek background that you have
and you bring that food to our Palace
what is Chef Nico Chef Nico what are you
making right now uh so I'm making a very
traditional appetizer uh saranagi
saganagi yeah it's very you know popular
special you know and this is what you
typically see that in America all the
time oh yeah yeah name it but we did a
little differently and um it's cheese
which is a Greek milk uh cheap smoked
cheese oh you had me and it's served on
this hot stone so throughout the eating
kind of processes things nice and warm
we'll let you continue making that but
tell us some of the other things because
I my mouth is just watering looking at
some of these dishes they look so fresh
yeah so what Nico does is kind of Keeps
Us in line with tradition yeah but then
I kind of come in and as you can see
kind of my influence things should start
looking familiar there so we have a
crispy chicken sandwich what we do with
that we take the baklavan dough and we
crust it in the chicken and fry it oh
man so that's our kind of version of
that we have our classic ghito and some
french fries we have our rice bowls with
quinoa classic Greek salad
um some lamb chops which you go into the
more traditional kind of appetizers
domadakia which is stuffed grape leaves
hummus Tzatziki some fresh vegetables to
dip in and you guys are classic desserts
you're expanding too we are so we opened
in 2017 yeah for rainbow and chop soon
after we have
um uh Buffalo uh-huh Malaki Buffalo
uh Centennial just opened we have Meraki
Charleston and we have minaki Stephanie
coming oh my gosh and you can you can
experience this deliciousness absolutely
I love you guys take on these classic
Greek dishes and Chef Nico that smells
fantastic how do you stay fantastic in
it's not actually work how do you say
wonderful delicious
oh I love it you guys check them out
unbelievable we're going to be indulging
in some of this amazing Greek food and
make sure you check out naraki it's
amazing Kendall